non so se ve lo dico anzi non solo
ricordare a nessuno perché un gioco che
facevo cinque anni fa si chiama over
globe e ho visto che è uscito su tim e
della cosa bellissima over gol story luc
carl store iter une facciamo bear grylls
c'è la storia di over gru per le vite
che questo gioco di conigli e che si
danno i cazzotti in bocca botte da da da
conigli è infatti il gioco crasha spero
che il video vi sia piaciuto non c'ho
voglia di leggere le cose dice io mi
faccio la mia storia è a mio modo che ti
chiamata allora io sono sto coniglio
guardali che storia come ci arrivo lì è
matto
ho fatto sono vivo a posto cioè mi sono
abbattuto un po la testa però va bene ok
la vacatio arrivato cosa ci faccio qua o
salve
non andrò mai con te è il tu sembri
grande e grosso dominavo questi ad mondo
dominato effetto aiuto salvami aiuto ai
a va da fuoco scherzava non volevo c'è
male ma chi ti conosce domina sto tizio
senti zio e non voglio litigare però se
devo picchiarti hanno subito l'hack è
male tua madre hai rotto il pene vai giù
di che calcione a posto tutto salvato è
ciao
va bene non so come ci si para l'hack è
male che c'erano i calci potevi dare dal
mondo
tipo bella gente cosa fate sopra la casa
sono qui io e la mia dop e ninja che
vale ai mi ha spaccato
non sapevo di poter fare questa cosa
bene torniamo per l'altro perfetto a
posso tirare giù la gente finissimo eni
non mi hanno spiegato i tassi che ne so
per come farlo anche lui però ok tua
sorella
a questo è morto e un coniglio morto
poverino dispiace c'è qualcuno che
chiede aiuto lo vedo questo sembra
proprio un lavoro per rabbit man ha poi
crollare mentre sei in aria e cadere
rovinosamente fantastico salve giorno
del ringraziamento sti maledetti
americani americani
avete qua davanti una mary coniglio vi
faccio culo io
prendetevela con qualcuno della vostra
taglia a sarà meno tra di loro
vabbè io guardo 1x sul blu ecco perso
madonna che calcio in volte va beh un
orto perfetto manca ancora uno senso
gioco non riescono ad anni entrambi gli
altri mi ambiento da solo con un 3 non
riusciamo a farlo fuori
tagliate male ha trovato colte a caso
dovevo preso o disarmato lui
ok andato mi sa che è andata si calma
calma calma posto a posto io devo andare
posso andare vado ancora qualche
fenomeno guardalo superman è quasi ma io
posso andare anche senza sono anche a
puglisi mamma mia che brutta mira male
male male male 1 andato sta facendo cosa
fai presso cooper lanciare l'idea non
sapevo ha posto ai a premi e prendiamo
vai male come r
ma lo sbattono indietro giochi adesso
con un cane questo ciao cane ok ciao
cane l'ho ucciso
mi sono schiantato per terra però l'ho
ucciso stiamo liberando degli schiavi
dalla schiavitù di sta gente questo che
dobbiamo fare niente di difficile se non
fosse che con gli hanno dei machete
rifarmi disarmare prima tipo col machete
qui passiamo agli altri ma la schiuma
cede mai più bello stomaci o disarmato
no per farmi focus aia che è male
va bè cosa vedo
l'ha lanciata l'ha lanciata dov'è
ecco la mamma mia la strage
bravo ecco fate le cose voi dove c'è un
promuovi salve ho vinto io
la madre michevole navi cia primitive da
riassumere quello che ci fosse stata era
popolata di animali selvatici
cioè noi che poi è stata conquistata da
questa gente che è arrivata con le navi
e sta sotto mettendo tutti io sono uno
di quelli che li deve liberare credo sia
così la storia credo è questo è il mio
stealth che non va a farsi benedire
strano devo batterli tutti io basta che
arriva la nave complimenti con
bravissimo sì che sei un james bond nato
esattamente così bravi non potete nulla
contro di me neanche questi pistacchi
ma quanto sono storto da una mille ok
con o che è andato effetto vai vai
prendi il trenino prima evitarli tutti
che sono mi fanno il culo tanto posso
passare dall acqua credo di no però
vediamo se ci arrivo sul ponte si no
sono un idiota c'è uno che la spada
grossa da mela me grazie a muro fan 2
bene let's go europei
cessalto film di non ci credo potrei
arrivarci ci sono in atto per miracolo
buongiorno 1 ae acqua bene
ci sono arrivato per miracolo
prendila effetto non provavo i nemici ma
chi siamo tu
da dove è uscito quell'altro ma dai non
vale e vabbè dai non valere che è uscito
un tizio dal nulla
si vabbè dai mezzi a 1
prendilo bold 2 premio non c'era il poli
mezzo c'era anche un altro per i mezzi
sono storto come la morte all 81
2263 detto 3 ho detto 3 andate faccio
finita
no no che la spada e buona porca vacca
ma il capoclan il capo cane un altro
tizio ancora un altro boss è morto
subito
lui l'ho battuto subito nel dorato un
secondo il gatto rosa siete liberi
adesso
ok avete freddo e si vede lei no lei non
ha freddo li fa la sexy allora mi un po
avanti vediamo cosa succede quando
friesland tra i ghiacciai è già
difficile fare è un misto tra
combattimento e parkour sto gioco è
bellissimo perché non l'avevo più fatto
c'è ma io vi giuro so gioco ragazzi ci
giocavo cinque anni fa veramente se
scrivete fa vj overclock su youtube
trovate il mio video tipo di avevo
ancora i denti da latte quando avevo
registratore video e non era così era
tipo una porco schifo sono caduto
non era così era un'arena dove ti dove
combattevi contro gente
ok che vabbè vabbè diventa sempre più
fitch e l'altro partitura maledizione
che piano piano stai fermo nomi sono che
devo andare a giugno che testata raga a
fare parkour faccio schifo però va beh
il mio dio
queste pazzie volete far arrivare
scusate ma basta quanto pazzi maniaci ci
sono arrivato non so come mai nella vita
vai vai vai gesù manca l'ultima
sull'ultimo saltino l'ultimo santino
eccolo qui salve c'è un lupo lo vedo un
po di fortuna a pensieri potermi
uccidere ma va avanti
ok questo potrebbe essere un problema
come che si prendono le armi dov'è che
mi è caduto soprattutto caduta nomi con
la ricaduta lo prende a pugni
l'ho vinto io come fa e vabbè ma non
posso anche schivare i colpi c'è più che
schivare i colpi lo direi posso anche
trattenere i colpi questo gigante a
proviamoci dai ottimo forse muoio
sei morto dispiacere sarebbe a posto
meno male che sei la gnocca basta
ragazzo cotto fatemi sapere se volete
continuo e veramente bello meglio di
quando era cinque anni fa anche io sono
un po meglio però dovrei togliere
comunque i capelli che vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi come sia venuto mi piace che il
riferimento di vestizione so se l'avete
di telefono ci vediamo e io dovrei avere
la coordinazione per fermare dei colpi
di kung fu non so manco prendere un
telecomando in aria beh ragazzi
[Musica]